[Aplausos]
cuando asumí como directora de la
carrera sistemas acá en la universidad
encontré solo dos chicas estudiando en
los cinco años de la carrera así que
comencé a involucrarme en las
actividades de promoción y en en cada
oportunidad de las chicas pasar lo más
lejos posible en esta ingeniería lejos
urgen entonces cuando puedo conversar
con algún con alguna de las chicas les
pregunto se han considerado a hacer
alguna carrera relacionada con la
tecnología y la respuesta más frecuente
suele ser o que no sirven para eso o que
piensan que no les gusta
y yo la verdad que creo que la mayoría
ni sabe qué es lo que hacemos el asunto
es que en una conversación de unos pocos
minutos es difícil cambiar la percepción
que tienen de sí mismas y de la carrera
en argentina y en otros países existe
una brecha de género en las disciplinas
denominadas setting es decir ciencia
tecnología ingeniería y matemática y
esta brecha se ve tanto las
universidades como en el ámbito laboral
y es que muchas veces hemos escuchado
que las mujeres somos demasiado
sensibles o demasiado cálidas para este
tipo de profesiones
evidentemente que no todas las mujeres
en ese estereotipo pero sería malo
llevar la sensibilidad a la ciencia o la
ingeniería
sería algo negativo tener una visión más
humanizada de los avances de la
tecnología y de paso estas habilidades
blandas son las más demandadas en este
tipo de disciplinas
hay estudios que indican que la
diversidad de género en la gestión de
las organizaciones produce un impacto
positivo y que se obtienen mejores
resultados financieros es decir las
empresas que tienen más diversidad de
género suelen tener mejor rendimiento y
ser más innovadores y más creativas es
que las mujeres somos distintas tenemos
una forma distinta de pensar y eso
precisamente nos hace valiosas para las
organizaciones
pero sin embargo somos pocas las que
decidimos estudiar carreras relacionadas
con la tecnología o con la ingeniería o
con la ciencia
es posible que la leyenda urbana de que
todos los que estudian tecnología o los
que se dedican a informática son raros o
nerd disuada un poco dejen a las chicas
de estudiar tecnología pero la verdad es
que si una chica a pesar de eso decide
estudiar una carrera relacionada
se encuentra con ambientes
masculinizados y se encuentra con
situaciones donde tengo que soportar
chistes machistas o comentarios fuera de
lugar y estos comportamientos se ven
también en el ámbito laboral con la
segregación horizontal que aísla a la
mujer o al grupo de mujeres y la
segregación vertical que produce lo que
conocemos como el techo de cristal que
nos impide ocupar puestos de liderazgo y
puestos gerenciales
hace unos cuantos años una persona que
prestamos servicio al departamento donde
yo trabajaba me pregunto cómo hace para
trabajar vos solita con todos estos
hombres
yo te agarre sin arrancando y la verdad
es que en ese momento no entendí bien
por qué me planteaba eso
estamos hablando de mis compañeros de
trabajo un es que yo estaba comprando
escribió el escritorio con un grupo de
acosadores pero con el tiempo entendí de
que ciertos ambientes pueden ser
intimidantes para las mujeres por está
de minoría y solo para estar en minoría
otra los factores que influyen en la
inserción de las mujeres en este
ambiente laboral tan competitivo es la
falta de conciliación entre la vida
personal y familiar y la vida laboral en
la mente de mucha gente está instalada
la idea de que si somos madres tenemos
que estar dispuestas a pagar un alto
costo profesional y por el contrario si
vos quieres destacar profesionalmente
tenés que renunciar a la maternidad
pero esta falta de conciliación entre la
vida familiar personal y laboral también
afecta a los hombres por lo que tienen
vida propia pero por otro lado porque si
son padres la presencia en la vida de
sus hijos es igualmente importante que
la nuestra entonces pienso que la lucha
es que esta lucha no debería recaer
solamente sobre las mujeres
en muchas organizaciones y universidades
que entienden esto y tratan de hacer un
ambiente más amigable para las mujeres
entonces crean por ejemplo un día de
concientización crean grupos de apoyo o
incluso dan posibilidades de
conciliación con la vida personal mis
alumnos me sugirieron por qué no hacemos
un grupo de whatsapp para las chicas
para poder apoyar a las chicas de la
carrera la verdad es que a mí esta idea
no me termine de cerrar que yo no quiero
segregar las yo creo que ellas se
sienten incluidas entonces todos estos
paliativos nunca van a ser suficientes
me parece de que los ambientes no son
poco amigables porque todo los hombres
sean machistas sino que a veces el hecho
de que haya pocas mujeres en ciertos
círculos hace que se vayan creando o
generando estos ecosistemas así
misóginas pero no siempre pasa yo he
tenido por tenía de trabajar con un
montón de colegas de grupos de colegas
donde el ambiente salud laboral había
sido saludable
así que entonces si otros pensamos que
para las organizaciones para la economía
es bueno que se involucren más mujeres
cómo hacemos para lograrlo
porque intentar de que los que las aulas
o que los ambientes laborales sean
amigables para las mujeres es un buen
paso pero me parece que tenemos que
mirar
y mucho tiempo atrás o sea cuando las
chicas todavía no decidieron que van a
estudiar en la universidad entonces
hay estudios que indican que existe la
misma proporción de nenas que de nenes
diagnosticados como altas capacidades es
decir superdotados lo que antes
conocemos como superdotados incluso en
algunos países es más alta la proporción
de nenas que den en es así que la la su
representación de las mujeres en estas
disciplinas no se debe a una capacidad
intelectual inferior
en el tiempo a pensar en esto y se me
ocurrió que quizás este problema tenga
cierta analogía con el cultivo de bonsai
si nosotros queremos hacer un bonsai lo
que tengo que hacer es tomar una
plantita del árbol que queremos
convertir en bonsai y empezar a podar
sus ramas y tenemos que hacerlo
consistentemente a medida que la
plantilla va creciendo y de la misma
forma una forma similar
cada vez que nosotros decimos los barón
heras este juego es para varones no es
para chicas cada vez que una narración
su cumpleaños una muñeca esa número
recibe un robot o un telescopio
cada vez que invadimos los sentidos de
las nenas con el concepto de mujer
frágil siempre secundando las activas
masculina la mujer detrás del gran
hombre
o quizás cada vez que las relegamos
exclusivamente a los roles de madre de
esposa de cuidadora del hogar estamos
pagando sus ramas
y seguimos jugando cuando era el
secundario entonces le decimos porque no
sé es una carrera más relacionadas con
las ciencias humanas o sociales porque
no elegí una profesión que te permita
trabajar en otro lado cuando tu esposo
lo trasladen aunque no tienes ni novio
ni ellos decidió si vas a tener hijos o
no
entonces desde chicas se nos va marcando
un camino condicionando las decisiones
que tomaremos en el futuro únicamente
basados en nuestra condición de mujer
sin tener en cuenta las habilidades o
los intereses personales
aunque la admisión a una carrera de la
universidad no discrimine por género la
poda ya se hizo antes
hace un tiempo recibí en mi oficina a
una mamá que me contó la preocupación
que tenía cuando era chica porque acá es
que recibí una muñeca en lugar en el
guarda kunar la la desarmaba porque
quería ver cómo hacía para hablar o sea
lo que sea de zermatt o entonces me
confesó que le daba mucho alivio verme a
mí como profesional de la disciplina
casada con hijos chiquititos
eso pensaba la preocupación de tener
hijas que no encajen es real nuestra
cultura nos lleva a eso
desde la escuela y de la familia se
pueden luchar por combatir estos
estereotipos se pueden desarrollar
actividades
donde las chicas puedan experimentar y
perder el miedo a cometer esos errores
por sentirse menos aptas también
se puede invitar profesionales de la
disciplina para que puedan contar sus
experiencias mujeres que estén en esta
línea y que permiten a las chicas poder
verse en ese en ese rol
e
los resultados de una investigación que
se realizó en eeuu
indicaban que los varones y las negras
de seis años seis años ya sostenía el
estereotipo de que los varones eran
mejor en robótica de programación
sin embargo cuando las nenas habían
tenido experiencia previa en
programación demostraban un alto interés
tecnológico y autoeficacia para la tarea
así que esa es otra buena actividad como
para hacer en la escuela
vamos a enseñar programación y para
contraer el crecimiento del bonsai
también necesitamos recortar las raíces
que están debajo de la tierra y de una
manera similar el micromachismo también
va recortando la confianza propia de las
mujeres desde que son pequeñas entonces
cada vez que escuchan que los varones
son mejor que con los números que las
mujeres somos complicados para trabajar
que hablamos demasiado que son
muchísimos estás
es que no sabemos liderar que nos
embarazo nos entramos en licencia que
escuchamos esto también se están
recortando nuestras raíces creo que si
fuéramos un poco más conscientes del
efecto que tiene nuestras palabras en
los demás si tuviéramos más cuidado con
estas expresiones que hacemos decimos a
veces
podríamos ayudar a las chicas a crecer
con una autoestima más saludable
y la maceta la maceta donde ponemos el
11 y también es importante ya que quiero
hacer un paréntesis porque cuando le
contaba esta idea esta analogía mi
esposo me dijo que posiblemente iba a
estar ofendiendo a los machistas y a los
cultivos de bonsai no machistas al mismo
tiempo así que solo quiero aclarar que
estoy hablando en contra de los que
condicionan el crecimiento intelectual
de las niñas y no tiene que ver con los
gonzález
pero bueno entonces volviendo a la
maceta la maceta es importante que el
bronce va a crecer tanto como se lo
permita su maceta
entonces los invito a prestar más
atención en los estantes de las
jugueterías los estantes de las nenas
todo rosado
y los roles que puede asumir como
pequeña mujer están muy centrados en la
maternidad en el cuidado de otros en el
cuidado de las tareas del hogar
y muchos enfocados en la estética o en
el cuidado personal por supuesto que los
varones también sufren estos
estereotipos cada vez que se los reprime
porque demuestran sensibilidad o algún
interés por una tarea doméstica la
verdad es que los los estantes de los
juguetes de los varones son distintos
están mucho más orientados al movimiento
al ocio a la razón resolución de
problemas tienen los juegos de varones
siempre el concepto de jerarquía y sin
embargo bueno incluso los videojuegos no
que permiten desarrollar habilidades
como como pensamiento estratégico toma
decisiones están más asociados los
varones
y en cambio los
los juegos de las nenas son más
pacíficos más tranquilos orientados a
las labores a la estética y al cuidado y
esto no es trivial
el juego infantil es el precursor de
comportamientos superiores que tienen
que ver con el trabajo con la ciencia y
con el arte
afortunadamente se ven cada vez más
ustedes habrán visto campañas
publicitarias y fabricantes que intentan
achicar esta brecha asi que tengamos en
cuenta la próxima vez que vayamos a
hacer un juguete un regalo a un juguete
a una nena porque a veces incluso una
pequeña acción puede hacer un gran
cambio en la vida de una persona
sin duda que hay características
personales que nos hacen más o menos
afines para determinadas disciplinas
pero muchas de esas características no
tienen que ver con el género sino quizás
con la forma en que hemos educado o
formado a cada uno entonces si nosotros
tratamos a las nenas siempre como
frágiles princesas si si nosotros les
permitimos determinados berrinches como
si fueran eso es parte de su adn estamos
pagando sus raíces lo que estamos
haciendo es generando mujeres adultas
con esas características y lo mismo si
nosotros estimulamos intelectualmente de
manera diferente a los varones que a las
nenas el resultado evidentemente que va
a ser distinto
volviendo al ejemplo de la muñeca y el
robot porque la muñeca tenga algo de
malo sino porque está bueno que las
nenas desarrollen otras habilidades
también con el juego como lo hacen los
varones
igual hoy hay chicas que eligen
tecnología muchas han tenido un familiar
que las ha incentivado otras han tenido
en su vida la presencia algún docente
mentor que el apoyo otras simplemente
tenían a crecer una maceta pero por cada
una de ellas hay un montón que están
desperdiciando su potencial o incluso
ignorando su vocación
por supuesto que cada uno de nosotros
tiene una responsabilidad personal de
identificar y desarrollar los talentos
con los que nació las habilidades con
las que nació
pero como padres como educadores como
sociedad en general tenemos cierta
responsabilidad por la cantidad de
mujeres que quedan relegadas a trabajos
muy por debajo de sus capacidades o que
no las motivan y no las estimulan
podemos estar cultivando bonsai día a
día con nuestras palabras y con nuestras
y con nuestras acciones
entiendo que para muchos esto es un
proceso automático es algo inconsciente
y que nos sale para otros se adopta una
postura como para desvincularse de
ciertas luchas ideológicas con las que
no quiere tener nada que ver pero no
todas ellas son iguales
cada persona debería tener las mismas
posibilidades de crecimiento y
desarrollo intelectual y profesional y
eso independientemente del género
todo esto comienza en la primera
infancia
lo que les estuve contando hoy no son
temas meramente conceptuales para mí son
cosas que yo vivo día a día y aunque les
confieso que a veces no es fácil
estoy realmente muy feliz satisfecha con
la profesión que elegí me siento útil y
tanto así que quiero que mi hija también
puede tener un desarrollo intelectual no
condicionado y los invito a ustedes a
intentar lo mismo en su familia o con
las niñas de su familia
y
[Aplausos]
[Música]